Adolf Hitler dans sa retraite
de la montagne bavaroise.
Nous sommes en septembre 1938,
Et Hitler vient de s'engager
dans une voie encore plus dangereuse,
Que toutes celles qu'il
avait osé prendre jusque là.
Il a proclamé territoire allemand,
La région des Sudètes de Tchécoslovaquie,
Et la puissante armée tchécoslovaque
s'est mobilisé pour la guerre.
La Tchécoslovaquie étant alliée
à la France et à l'Angleterre,
La guerre signifierait une conflagration
qui engouffrerait l'ensemble de l'Europe.
Hitler est convaincu qu'il
arrivera à ses fins,
Sans provoquer de désastre.
En 1935, il s'était lancé dans
une énorme campagne de réarmement.
L'année suivante,
Malgré les conseils de ses généraux,
Il avait défié la France et l'Angleterre,
Et réoccupé la Rhénanie démilitarisée.
Comme Hitler l'avait prédit,
les Alliés ne firent rien.
En mars 1938, il avait annexé
de force l'Autriche à l'Allemagne.
Une fois de plus,
La France et l'Angleterre n'ont rien fait.
Hitler est désormais convaincu
que pour vaincre en Tchécoslovaquie,
Tout ce qu'il a à faire est
de mobiliser ses armées,
Et toute résistance disparaîtra.
Dans l'Europe toute entière,
les exigences d'Hitler sèment la consternation.
Les horreurs de la Grande Guerre
toujours vives dans les mémoires,
Rares sont ceux qui osent envisager la terreur,
Qu'engendrerait un autre conflit.
Dans les rues des villes anglaises,
Des tranchées apparaissent dans
presque tous les espaces ouverts.
Et les édifices publics disparaissent
derrière de grands murs de sacs de sable.
C'est la semaine de la crise de Munich.
La paix en Europe et mon objectif.
J'espère que ce voyage en ouvrira la voie.
Dans une tentative désespérée
pour éviter la guerre,
Le Premier ministre britannique,
Neville Chamberlain, se rend en Allemagne.
À chaque fois, Hitler fait monter la pression.
Il semble que la guerre est inévitable.
C'est le dictateur italien, Mussolini,
Qui suggère une dernière tentative,
Pour préserver la paix avec la conférence
des quatre grandes puissances européennes.
Le 30 septembre 1938 à Munich,
Le sort de la Tchécoslovaquie est réglé.
Pendant que les envoyés tchécoslovaques
sont forcés d'attendre à l'extérieur,
De la salle de conférence,
L'Angleterre, la France et l'Italie
concèdent à Hitler les Sudètes.
Ce matin, j'ai eu une autre conversation
avec le chancelier allemand Herr Hitler.
Voici le document qui porte
son nom ainsi que le mien.
Nous considérons l'accord signé la nuit dernière,
Et l'accord naval anglo-allemand symbolique,
Du désir de nos 2 peuples,
De ne jamais entrer à nouveau en guerre.
En Angleterre,
La réaction à la déclaration de Chamberlain,
La paix en notre temps,
Entraîne une jubilation sans réserve.
L'admiration devant la réussite
de Chamberlain est si grande,
Qu'il devient le premier des chefs
de gouvernement britannique,
À être présenté au peuple du
balcon du palais de Buckingham.
L'euphorie de Munich dure à peine 6 mois.
En mars 1939, l'Allemagne annexe
ce qu'il reste de la Tchécoslovaquie.
Cette violation flagrante des accords de Munich,
Choque même ceux qui soutenaient
la politique d'apaisement de Chamberlain.
Aux yeux du public britannique,
Hitler est maintenant un agresseur
que rien ne pourra arrêter.
Pratiquement tout le monde s'accorde à dire,
Que la fois prochaine,
Guerre ou pas guerre,
on lui résistera.
Au premier rang de l'opposition à l'apaisement,
Se tient l'homme politique anglais,
Winston Churchill.
Les appels de Churchill à résister contre Hitler,
Ainsi que l'introduction de la conscription,
Touchent la corde sensible du peuple anglais.
La faiblesse militaire de ce pays,
Encourage les ennemis potentiels.
Tout le monde sait que l'opinion
publique ne fait que grandir,
En faveur du service national obligatoire
sous toutes ses formes,
Particulièrement sous la plus haute de ses formes.
Le gouvernement de Chamberlain est obligé de répondre.
Dans les semaines qui suivent
l'invasion de la Tchécoslovaquie,
L'Angleterre introduit la conscription
pour tous les hommes de 18 à 20 ans.
Pour des milliers de jeunes hommes
arrachés aux usines,
Aux fermes et aux universités.
La vie consiste maintenant en
des rondes infinissables,
Et à la vie de routine dans les casernes.
Peu d'entre eux, se rendent compte,
Que dans un peu plus de 5 mois,
Leur pays sera en guerre avec l'Allemagne.
Ignorant le changement d'humeur considérable
qui vient de se produire en Angleterre,
Hitler passe à la phase suivante
de son programme de conquête.
Cette fois, il réclame le port de Memel,
Qui avait fait partie par
le passé de l'Empire germanique.
Impuissante face à la puissance allemande,
La Lituanie cède Memel.
Encouragé, Hitler regarde maintenant
en direction de la Pologne.
Le port balte de Dantzig est
relié à la Pologne depuis 1918,
Par un corridor considéré comme territoire polonais.
Le couloir polonais sépare la Prusse
Orientale du reste de l'Allemagne.
Hitler, avec le soutien d'une puissante
faction nazie au sein de la ville,
Exige de prendre possession de Dantzig
et de fermer le couloir.
Lorsque la Pologne fait preuve d'obstination,
Hitler commence à faire des menaces.
Cette fois, l'effet est inverse
à celui qu'il avait prévu.
Loin d'abandonner la Pologne,
Neville Chamberlain, piqué au vif
par l'humiliation après Munich,
Rédige de sa main une garantie britannique
de l'indépendance de la Pologne.
C'est une garantie qui a de faibles
significations sur le plan militaire,
Mais Hitler est furieux et ordonne à
ses généraux de se préparer à l'invasion.
Avant de lâcher ses armées,
Hitler renforce sa position internationale.
Le pacte d'acier entre l'Allemagne et l'Italie
est signé le 22 mai.
Le 23 août, un pacte de non-agression
est conclu avec l'Union soviétique de Staline.
Le pacte est destiné à s'assurer que l'U.R.S.S
ne s'opposera pas activement à l'invasion.
Des accords secrets sont passés
entre l'Allemagne et l'Union soviétique,
Pour le partage de la Pologne conquise.
Des Polonais piégés entre deux empires affamés,
Leurs plus proches alliés à
des centaines de kilomètres,
Se mobilisent rapidement pour la guerre.
Le 1ᵉʳ septembre 1939,
Les armées d'Hitler passent
la frontière polonaise.
Alors que les formations blindées allemandes
traversent sans difficulté les défenses polonaises,
La Luftwaffe, attaque les postes de commandement,
Les jonctions ferroviaires et
les concentrations de troupes.
L'objectif est d'isoler le champ de bataille
en détruisant les moyens de communication.
Une telle coordination des forces
terrestres et aériennes,
Représente une forme de guerre
entièrement nouvelle.
Un journaliste italien lui donne
le nom qui la fera entrer dans l'histoire,
Il l'appelle Blitzkrieg, la guerre éclair.
La résistance polonaise est
courageuse mais sans espoir.
Des équipements inadéquates ainsi
que des tactiques obsolètes,
Ne peuvent rivaliser avec la puissance
et la rapidité de l'assaut allemand.
Le désastre est aggravé par la répugnance
du haut commandement polonais,
À retirer ses forces pour défendre
plus facilement ses positions,
Dans le centre de la Pologne.
Bientôt, il est trop tard.
Avec l'anéantissement des forces
aériennes à terre et les bombardiers Stuka,
Toujours prêts à attaquer,
Les mouvements de troupes,
deviennent véritablement impossible.
Les divisions polonaises,
Les unes après les autres,
Sont encerclées et détruites.
Le 3 septembre, Neville Chamberlain
s'adresse au peuple anglais.
Ce matin, l'ambassadeur de
Grande-Bretagne à Berlin,
A remis au gouvernement allemand une note finale,
Signifiant que,
À moins qu'il annonce avant 11h
son intention de retirer ses troupes de Pologne,
L'état de guerre existera entre nous.
Je dois vous annoncer maintenant,
Que nous n'avons reçu aucun
engagement de cette sorte,
Et en conséquence,
Ce pays est en guerre avec l'Allemagne.
Dans les minutes qui suivent
l'annonce de Chamberlain,
Les sirènes de raids aériens
de Londres retentissent,
Et on assiste à une course
frénétique en direction des abris.
C'est une fausse alerte,
Mais la peur de la puissance
destructrice des bombardements,
A des racines profondes.
Le gouvernement britannique a
prévu 600 000 morts civils,
Pour les 2 premiers mois de la guerre.
Les nouvelles en provenance de Pologne,
Ne font qu'accentuer la peur
des bombardements de masse,
Qui hantent la population britannique.
À partir du 10 septembre,
La ville de Varsovie est assiégée par les Allemands.
Refusant de se rendre,
Ses habitants sont bombardés sans merci.
Des dizaines de milliers d'entre eux
meurent dans les ruines de la ville.
Le jour où l'Angleterre a déclaré
la guerre à l'Allemagne,
La France l'a suivie à contrecœur.
Les forces militaires françaises,
Sont les plus grandes et les
plus puissantes en Europe.
Et alors que la quasi totalité,
De l'armée allemande est engagée
dans la campagne de Pologne,
Une attaque française sur la
frontière occidentale de l'Allemagne,
Rencontrerait une faible opposition.
Au lieu de prendre l'offensive,
La France se contente de
renforcer sa ligne Maginot,
Et d'attaquer les Allemands dans
des luttes d'artillerie occasionnelles.
Pendant ce temps, les armées polonaises,
Ne peuvent que se battre et
espérer que les Français agiront.
Le 17 septembre, les Polonais
subissent le coup final.
Avec la complicité de l'Allemagne,
Les troupes soviétiques
envahissent l'Est de la Pologne.
Le gouvernement polonais est forcé
de s'enfuir en exil.
La destruction de l'État polonais,
N'est que le début de l'agonie dans
laquelle le peuple polonais,
Est maintenant plongé.
Non content d'une simple conquête,
Hitler est convaincu que le peuple polonais,
Doit devenir un peuple d'esclaves
au service de son nouvel ordre.
Afin de s'assurer qu'il n'y aura
pas de rébellion à l'avenir,
Les Polonais les plus éduqués
et les plus influents,
Ce qui comprend les médecins, les avocats
et les membres du clergé,
Sont rassemblés et exécutés de façon sommaire.
Au même moment, annonçant les
prémices de l'Holocauste,
Les Juifs de Pologne sont mis
de force dans des ghettos,
En attendant les déportations et les assassinats.
D'une population juive de 3 millions en Pologne,
2 millions et demi seront tués
dans les camps de la mort.
Alors que les combats sont pratiquement terminés,
Hitler est libre d'envoyer ses
propres armées à l'Ouest,
Pour défendre sa frontière avec la France.
Fait ignoré de la France et de l'Angleterre,
L'Allemagne a presque épuisé ses
ressources en carburant et en munitions.
S'il avait été attaqué à l'Ouest,
Il est pratiquement certain Hitler
aurait été obligé d'en finir.
Il faudra attendre 5 longues années,
Avant que l'Allemagne ne soit à
nouveau aussi vulnérable.
Avec la chute de la Pologne,
Cela ne fait pas l'ombre d'un doute
pour l'Angleterre et la France,
Qu'Hitler va attaquer à l'Ouest.
Le point d'attaque le plus probable,
Est non pas à la frontière française
où la ligne Maginot présente un obstacle formidable,
Mais plus au nord, en Belgique neutre.
Pour contrer un tel mouvement,
Une force expéditionnaire britannique
de 150 000 hommes et de 24 000 véhicules,
A été envoyée en France.
Ils se tiennent maintenant prêt
à une avancée rapide en Belgique,
Dans le cas ou une attaque
allemande semblerait imminente.
Alors que l'automne fait place à l'hiver,
L'invasion prévue ne se matérialise pas.
C'est le début d'une difficile accalmie
surnommée par un journaliste américain,
La drôle de guerre.
Pendant qu'à terre la guerre
est prise dans une impasse,
En mer, une bataille mortelle fait rage.
On compte 79 navires coulés
par les mines allemandes,
Près des côtes anglaises à Noël 1939.
Les sous marins patrouillent et,
Bien qu'Hitler ne soit parti en guerre
qu'avec 23 sous marins seulement,
Une fraction du nombre réclamé par ses amiraux,
Il ne tarde pas à se faire un nom.
*
Les forces navales britanniques ont à
leur tête un nouveau ministre de la Marine.
Winston Churchill a été nommé au
gouvernement au début de la guerre.
Sa réputation est connue des
responsables de la propagande allemande,
Et il est la cible de programmes
injurieux envers les Anglais,
Diffusés par une nouvelle station
de radio allemande.
Churchill propose maintenant que
l'Angleterre prenne l'offensive en mer,
Plus près du territoire national.
Reprenant un plan du ministère de
la Marine datant de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Il suggère que l'Angleterre et la France,
Posent des mines dans les eaux
de la Norvège neutre,
Et empêche de cette façon l'exportation
du minerai de fer suédois,
En direction de l'Allemagne.
Mais mieux encore, il faudrait que les Alliés
se lancent dans une expédition pour prendre Narvik,
Le port norvégien qui détient une position clé.
D'ici avril 1940, une force expéditionnaire
de 14 000 hommes est rassemblée,
Prête à s'embarquer vers Narvik.
La pose de mines a commencé.
Hitler sait que l'Angleterre a
l'intention d'intervenir en Norvège.
Jusqu'alors, il se contentait de
tirer profit des avantages commerciaux,
Offerts par la neutralité norvégienne.
Le plan des Alliés l'oblige à réagir.
C'est à l'aube ce matin que
la première information tomba,
Indiquant que les troupes allemandes
sont en train de franchir la frontière,
Pour entrer au Danemark.
Au même moment, des attaques étaient
lancées à partir du large,
Sur plusieurs des principaux ports norvégiens.
La force expéditionnaire des Alliés,
Qui attendait d'entrer en action en Norvège,
Est envoyée à la hâte d'Angleterre
dans une tentative désespérée,
Pour déloger les Allemands du port norvégien.
Mal calculée et mal prévue,
L'opération est vouée
à l'échec dès son commencement.
Un appui naval puissant ne peut compenser
l'insuffisance de la couverture aérienne des Alliés.
De plus, la troupe, forte de 30 000 hommes,
Est sous équipée pour la guerre
dans le climat rude de Norvège.
Pilonnés par les attaques aériennes allemandes,
Les Alliés tiendront 3 mois avant
d'être finalement évacués,
Après avoir subi de lourdes pertes
en navires et en hommes.
Alors que la tragédie de la
campagne norvégienne se déroule,
Le peuple britannique ne rejette
pas la responsabilité sur Churchill,
Mais sur Neville Chamberlain.
Il règne une grande déception
quant à la conduite de la guerre.
Son coût pour la nation s'élève
à 6 millionsde livres par jour,
Et peu de choses sont là pour en témoigner.
Pire encore, le gouvernement ne
prend pas les mesures,
Qui semblent pourtant évidentes.
1 million d'hommes sont au chômage,
Alors que la production industrielle
devrait être la première des priorités.
Le prix des produits de première
nécessité croît rapidement,
Et un programme de rationnement,
N'est pas encore mis en place
pour assurer une distribution équitable.
Le 8 mai 1940, la coupe des
mécontentements est pleine.
Critiquant le cabinet de guerre,
Mr Attlee a déclaré,
Partout c'est la même histoire.
Trop tard.
Pour gagner la guerre,
Il faut que d'autres
personnes soient à la barre.
Faisant suite aux débats des députés
sans portefeuille du gouvernement,
Mr Attlee a cité la déclaration
bien connue d'Oliver Cromwell.
Cela fait trop longtemps que vous êtes ici,
Pour le peu de bien que vous avez fait.
Partez, dis-je,
Qu'on en finisse avec vous,
au nom de Dieu, partez !
J'ai demandé une audience auprès du Roi,
Et lui remis ma démission que
Sa Majesté a gracieusement accepté.
Sa Majesté a maintenant nommé mon ami
et collègue Monsieur Winston Churchill.
Ayant reçu le mandat de Sa Majesté,
J'ai formé un gouvernement d'hommes
et de femmes de chaque parti,
Et de presque toutes les opinions.
Nous avons eu des différends par le passé,
Mais maintenant un lien nous unit tous,
Faire la guerre jusqu'à ce que
la victoire nous appartienne.
Ne jamais céder à la soumission et à la honte,
Quel qu'en soit le prix et l'agonie à supporter.
*
Le cabinet de guerre britannique s'est réuni à 8h,
Le ministère de l'Intérieur avertit
la Défense civile,
Et la patrouille anti-raid
de se tenir en alerte.
À la lumière des événements de ce
matin en Hollande et en Belgique,
Le ministère déclare que le
port des masques à gaz,
Est devenu à nouveau nécessaire.
3 jours après l'assaut des
Allemands sur les Pays-Bas,
Une action rappelle la vulnérabilité
des villes aux bombardements aériens.
Alors que les Hollandais sont déjà
en négociations pour la paix,
Le centre de Rotterdam est bombardé.
600 personnes sont tuées et
78 000 sont sans abri.
Le 15 mai, l'armée hollandaise se rend,
Craignant des morts supplémentaires
parmi les civils.
Elle a subi 100 000 pertes,
Le quart de l'ensemble de sa force.
*
Je me tiens à la frontière franco-belge,
Nous regardons les longues files
de troupes et d'approvisionnement,
Et de canons britanniques passant
de France en Belgique.
À cette frontière se trouve un petit village,
Qui est a priori à moitié
français et à moitié belge,
Avec des tranchées des deux côtés.
Presque tout le village est dehors,
Et se tient dans les rues à
regarder les transports arriver.
L'accueil donné par les Belges
est vraiment fantastique.
Mais l'enthousiasme des Belges contraste
énormément avec la souffrance des réfugiés,
Dans des endroits comme Liège.
Nous avons vu plusieurs camions
remplis de ces gens tristes,
Et à un endroit sur une autre route,
Nous avons rencontré un petit groupe de Belges,
des vieillards, des femmes et des enfants.
Certains avec des couvertures
roulées sur leurs épaules,
Leurs quelques bien misérables sur le dos,
Ou portés à la main dans des valises bon marché.
*
Voici à peu près la situation lorsque
l'escadron britannique a reçu l'ordre d'attaquer.
Une troupe française était en train,
De se replier sur les lignes
de défense au Nord-Est d'Anvers,
Alors qu'elle était engagée dans une course,
Avec une colonne motorisée allemande
qui essayait de lui couper la route.
Il semblait impossible que les
Allemands puissent réussir,
Et c'est pourquoi l'ordre fut lancé,
Arrêter cette colonne allemande.
Mais les Allemands ont
encore bombardé aujourd'hui,
Surtout les routes principales,
les aérodromes, les réfugiés,
Et dans un village, ils ont même bombardé un hôpital.
Les stratèges des Alliés,
Avaient toujours pensé que les
bois denses et les collines des Ardennes,
Rendraient ce territoire impraticable aux chars.
Mais les Allemands se sont
préparés depuis des mois.
Le 10 mai, cette division Panzer,
Avec à leur tête le génie militaire,
Se fraie un chemin et traverse
les Ardennes jusqu'au Luxembourg,
Et au sud de la Belgique.
Une fois la forêt traversée,
L'obstacle majeur qui se présente
au-delà des Allemands est la Meuse.
La poignée de division française
qui défend le secteur des Ardennes,
S'est retirée de l'autre côté du fleuve.
De là, elle rassemble toutes
les armes disponibles,
Dans une tentative désespérée,
Pour repousser la traversée des Allemands.
Un échange féroce d'artillerie prend
place pendant toute la nuit du 12 mai.
Le lendemain matin,
Les Français sont pilonnés
par les bombardiers,
Pendant que les troupes de choc allemandes,
Traversent la rivière sous des tirs violents.
Pendant que les forces d'élite établissent
et tiennent les têtes de pont,
Le génie militaire travaille fébrilement
à la construction de passages,
Pour les blindés allemands qui attendent.
Pendant que les Panzers traversent rapidement,
La Meuse à Sedan et à Dinant,
Les Français ne parviennent
à mettre en place,
Que quelques contre attaques désorganisées,
Qui sont rapidement écartées.
En l'espace de trois jours seulement,
Les Allemands ont fait une percée
dans les lignes françaises,
De 75 kilomètres de large.
Devant eux, la voie est ouverte
pour accéder au centre de la France.
*
Je vous parle pour la première fois
en tant que Premier ministre,
À un moment solennel de la vie de
notre pays, de notre empire, de nos alliés,
Et plus encore de la cause de la liberté.
Une bataille terrible fait rage
en France et en Flandre.
Les Allemands, par des bombardements
aériens combinés à des chars fortement blindés,
Ont percé la défense française
au nord de la ligne Maginot,
Et des rangs puissants de
leurs véhicules blindés,
Font des ravages sur les campagnes qui,
Pour le premier ou le deuxième jour,
se trouvaient sans défense.
Ils ont avancé loin à l'intérieur des terres,
Et répandu l'alarme et la confusion par leur puissance.
*
Derrière eux,
Arrive maintenant l'infanterie dans des camions,
Et derrière elle encore,
les grandes masses avancent.
Nous nous sommes battus à trois
ou quatre contre un avec nos ennemis.
En abattant les bombardier allemands,
Nous nous battons pour la bataille de France.
*
Après cette bataille de France aura
lieu la bataille sur notre île.
Pour l'Angleterre et pour tout ce qu'elle représente.
*
Dans ce cas d'urgence suprême,
Nous ne devront pas hésiter à
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires,
Et même les plus draconiennes.
Et demander à notre peuple de donner
le maximum et le meilleur de lui-même.
En l'espace d'une semaine, Boulogne se rend
et Calais est assiégée.
Alors que les deux bras de l'avancée allemande
ne sont éloignés que de 15 kilomètres seulement,
Le gros de la force expéditionnaire britannique,
Et une partie de la Première armée française,
Se retirent en direction de la ville de Dunkerque.
À présent, les Anglais ont perdu
la quasi totalité de leur artillerie lourde.
Les unités doivent combattre les chars avec
rien de plus que des mitraillettes et des grenades.
Puis, contre toute attente,
Les blindés allemands qui étaient
prêts à asséner le coup final,
Se retirent brusquement pour foncer sur Paris,
Bien que la bataille de Dunkerque
soit loin d'être terminée.
En Angleterre, une décision capitale a été prise.
La force expéditionnaire britannique
doit être évacuée par la mer.
Churchill prévient la Chambre des communes,
De se préparer à de dures
et de lourdes nouvelles.
Il ne dit pas que le gouvernement
prévoit de sauver seulement,
35 000 des 300 000 hommes piégés à Dunkerque.
Dès le début, il semble certain que
l'évacuation va être un échec colossal.
Les navires qui ont survécu au feu
roulant des attaques aériennes,
Aux champs de mines et aux torpilles,
Se retrouvent sous les tirs puissants
des armes allemandes à Calais.
Une fois dans le port de Dunkerque,
L'eau n'est pas suffisamment profonde
pour les plus gros navires.
Seulement 7000 hommes peuvent
être évacués le premier jour.
Le deuxième jour, une nouvelle voie
d'approche remporte de meilleurs résultats.
Sous le coup de redoutables attaques aériennes,
Les navires sauvent 47 000 hommes.
Mais le prix à payer est élevé,
En une journée, 3 destroyers ont été coulés
et 6 sérieusement endommagés.
Le port de Dunkerque est bloqué
par les navires endommagés,
Et toutes les autres évacuations
doivent se faire à partir des plages.
Néanmoins, l'opération continue.
Ceux qui y assiste savent qu'ils sont
les témoins de moments historiques.
Jour et nuit,
Des navires de tout type ont assuré
la liaison sur la Manche,
Sous les assauts des bombardiers ennemis,
Sans se soucier des dangers,
Et ont libéré les forces
expéditionnaire britannique enfermées,
Chaque navire étant plein à craquer
de soldats britanniques,
Meurtris par le combat et tachés de sang.
Peu après l'aube, ce matin,
J'ai observé deux navires de guerre
entrer dans le port,
Sous le poids énorme des hommes
qu'ils transportaient sur leur pont.
En quelques minutes, le commandement épuisé,
A accosté son navire et une passerelle
fut lancée de ses ponts vers le quai.
Les officiers de transport comptaient
les hommes alors qu'ils débarquaient.
Pas question d'unité, pas question de régiment,
Pas même question de nationalité,
Puisqu'il y avait des soldats
français et belges,
Qui se battaient aux côtés des Anglais
pendant la bataille des Flandres.
Ils étaient tous fatigués,
certains étaient complètement épuisés.
Le plus incroyable était que
presque tous les hommes,
Étaient d'une humeur plutôt gaie et
certains parvenaient même à sourire.
Même lorsqu'un homme était apparemment
sur le point de s'effondrer de fatigue.
Il était toujours possible de lire dans
ses yeux que son moral était irrépressible.
Et c'est quelque chose que tous les
bombardiers allemands n'écrasent auront jamais.
L'évacuation à Dunkerque est largement
considérée comme s'avoisinant du miracle.
338 000 hommes, parmi lesquels
139 000 soldats français ont été sauvés.
L'accueil qu'ils reçoivent en Grande-Bretagne
n'est pas celui d'une armée de vaincus,
Mais celle de héros d'un combat épique.
Churchill avertit que les guerres ne
se gagnent pas par des évacuations,
Mais Dunkerque transforme malgré
tout le moral des Anglais.
Avec la chute de Paris et la reddition
finale de la France le 21 juin,
Le sentiment se répand en Angleterre,
Qu'à elle seule, elle fera mieux.
Le problème est maintenant une
simple question de survie.
*
Ce que le général Weygand a appelé
la bataille de France est finie.
La bataille d'Angleterre va bientôt commencer.
De cette bataille dépend la survie
de la civilisation chrétienne.
D'elle, dépend notre propre vie en tant qu'Anglais,
La longue continuité de nos
institutions et de notre empire.
*
Toute la furie et toute la puissance de l'ennemi
vont bientôt se tourner vers nous.
Hitler sait qu'il devra nous
anéantir sur cette île,
Ou perdre la guerre.
Si nous pouvons lui faire face,
Toute l'Europe pourra être libre,
Et le monde pourra se diriger
vers des terres plus rayonnantes.
*
Mais si nous échouons, alors le monde
entier et même les Etats-Unis,
Y compris tous ceux que nous
avons connus et aimés,
Sombreront dans l'abysse d'un nouveau Moyen-Âge,
Faisant encore plus de sinistres,
Et restant plus longtemps à
l'ombre de la science pervertie.
*
Rassemblons nos forces afin de
remplir notre devoir,
Et faisons comme si l'Empire britannique
et le Commonwealth allait durer 1000 ans.
Les hommes diront en chœur,
C'était une époque de gloire.
*
Avec les armes de longue portée installées
sur les côtes de la France conquise,
L'Angleterre fait face pour
la première fois,
À la réalité de la guerre.
Pour les Anglais, ce sont des tirs
annonçant une campagne qui,
Beaucoup le craigne, ne peut qu'aboutir
à l'invasion par les nazis.
En dépit de la vulnérabilité de l'Angleterre,
Adolf Hitler ne souhaite pas pour l'instant,
S'engager dans des projets
d'invasion de grande échelle.
Il pense qu'avec la chute de la France,
L'Angleterre cherchera rapidement à négocier un accord.
Le 19 juillet, il fait une offre de paix.
D'une manière tout à fait caractéristique,
Elle est accompagnée d'une menace.
Si les Anglais refusent de voir
la réalité de la situation,
Une souffrance et une misère
infinie s'abattront sur eux.
La réponse de Churchill est typique.
Il refuse même de répondre,
L'Angleterre continuera le combat.
Au cours de l'été 1942, les armées
allemandes sur le front russe,
Ont une fois de plus rassemblé leurs forces.
La contre offensive soviétique à Moscou
avait été arrêtée,
les armées allemandes sauvées
de la débâcle totale,
Après le refus d'Hitler d'autoriser
le repli général.
Le chef du haut commandement
militaire et 35 généraux,
Ont été limogés et Hitler a pris personnellement
le contrôle de la guerre à l'Est.
Maintenant, il porte à nouveau son attention
sur ce qu'il convoite le plus,
Les champs pétrolifères du Caucase.
Plan bleu est le nom de code de la campagne.
Le 28 juin 1942, la grande offensive
commence avec le Groupe d'armées Sud,
Qui se lance en direction de l'est vers le Don,
En prenant la ville de Voronej.
Le corridor entre les rivières
du Don et du Donets,
Est maintenant en sécurité,
Et les Allemands peuvent commencer
leur grande avancée vers le sud.
Pour protéger la marche du Caucase,
Les forces allemandes sont divisées en deux.
Pendant qu'une partie avance dans
les champs pétrolifères du Sud,
L'autre doit attaquer et prendre la
ville stratégique de Stalingrad,
Coupant les moyens de communications
soviétiques dans le sud.
Alors que 300 000 troupes allemandes
sont engagées dans un combat épique,
Qui durera 5 mois,
En Afrique du Nord, les forces allemandes,
Sont également sur le point de
lancer une offensive historique.
À la fin du mois de juillet 1942,
dans le désert,
Les adversaires se sont battus
jusqu'au point d'être immobilisés.
Rommel manque désespérément d'approvisionnements,
Et surtout de carburant.
Mais en août, ses forces blindées ont augmenté.
Il dispose à présent de 203 chars
allemands et de 240 chars italiens.
Avec les attaques aériennes alliées
de plus en plus efficaces,
Sur les lignes d'approvisionnement déployées,
Rommel conclut qu'il doit attaquer immédiatement,
Dans l'espoir d'une victoire finale,
Ou faire face à une désintégration
progressive de sa force de combat.
Les Anglais reçoivent maintenant de
grandes quantités d'équipement américain,
Et le temps ne peut que jouer en leur faveur.
De plus, la huitième armée a un
nouveau commandant à sa tête,
Le lieutenant général Bernard Montgomery.
Ici, nous tiendrons et nous nous battrons.
Il n'y aura plus jamais de repli.
J'ai ordonné que tous les plans et consignes,
Concernant des replis de troupes
supplémentaires soient éliminés,
Et ce, immédiatement.
Nous tiendrons et nous nous battrons.
Après de longues préparations et
un important développement de supériorité,
En hommes et en équipement,
L'assaut de Montgomery est lancé
la nuit du 23 octobre.
La bataille d'El-Alamein commence par
un bombardement massif de l'artillerie britannique,
Suivie de près par des assauts de l'infanterie
sur les lignes de l'Axe, fortement miné.
Le succès du plan de Montgomery
dépend de l'infanterie,
Qui doit dégager un couloir que
les chars puissent traverser.
Les Italiens, qui bloquent l'avance britannique,
Opposent une forte résistance,
Et une contre attaque par la
15ᵉ Panzerdivision allemande,
N'est pas loin de couper court aux combats.
Le 25, un deuxième assaut par les
chars du 10ᵉ corps britannique,
Ne parvient toujours pas à
rompre les lignes de l'Axe.
Montgomery doit changer ses plans.
Des combats féroces font rage pendant une semaine,
Avant que Rommel soit finalement obligé
de reculer sur 15 kilomètres,
Pour éviter d'être encerclé.
Il manque rapidement d'approvisionnement,
Et sa force de chars s'amenuise progressivement.
Le 1ᵉʳ novembre, le coup décisif est porté.
Dans un assaut résolu,
La seconde division néo zélandaise
parvient à ouvrir un couloir,
Pour les blindés britanniques.
Rommel sait que s'il ne se retire pas,
Ses forces seront complètement détruites.
Hitler refuse avec véhémence
d'autoriser la retraite.
Pendant 2 jours désastreux,
Rommel obéit à ses ordres.
Finalement le 5 novembre,
de sa propre initiative,
Il décide de se retirer.
Il a perdu 35 000 hommes et il n'a plus que 22 chars.
En 1942, à la mi novembre,
La sixième armée allemande à Stalingrad,
A subi d'épouvantables pertes.
Chaque rue, chaque maison et chaque usine,
A été farouchement disputée.
Mais Hitler est convaincu que la Russie
ne tardera pas à s'effondrer.
En réalité, les armée secrète
soviétique de réserve,
Jusque là économisées,
Même dans les cas d'urgence les plus extrêmes,
Vont être lancées dans une immense contre offensive.
La bataille commence le 19 novembre.
En deux grandes poussées,
Les armées soviétiques brisent
les lignes italiennes en Roumanie,
Sur le flanc nord ouest de l'Allemagne.
Une troisième attaque frappe le sud.
Sous le poids d'un assaut
d'une telle férocité,
Les défenseurs de l'Axe sont dépassés.
Après 4 jours,
Les pointes des attaques soviétiques se rejoignent.
Un étau géant s'est resserré pour
encercler Stalingrad.
La sixième armée allemande,
Et une partie de l'armée de
la quatrième division Panzer,
C'est-à-dire 300 000 hommes,
Sont pris au piège dans les
ruines de la ville.
Comme on pouvait s'y attendre,
Hitler interdit toute tentative de recul.
Stalingrad doit être défendue jusqu'à
la dernière goutte de sang allemand.
Le 23 janvier 1943, l'Armée rouge
lance son dernier assaut.
Les défenseurs allemands, exténués,
Victimes du froid, affamés,
Et presque dépourvus de munitions,
Sont pris dans une poche qui
se rétrécit à vue d'œil.
Les tentatives de la Luftwaffe pour
les approvisionner par les airs,
Ont échoué depuis longtemps.
Et le dernier terrain d'aviation utilisable,
Est tombé entre les mains des Soviétiques.
En 11 jours, le combat est terminé.
Le commandement de la sixième armée,
Le général Von Paulus, se rend le 2 février.
150 000 Allemands sont morts,
90 000 sont faits prisonniers.
Seuls 7000 survivront.
Pour l'Allemagne, c'est le plus grand
désastre de son histoire militaire.
Pour les Alliés, c'est le tournant
décisif de la guerre.
Alors que la bataille de Stalingrad
faisait toujours rage.
Winston Churchill et Franklin Roosevelt,
S'étaient rencontrés à Casablanca, au Maroc.
Churchill avait clairement
exposé ses priorités.
Les Alliés doivent écraser les forces de l'Axe,
Qui sont encore en Tunisie,
Puis faire sortir l'Italie de la guerre.
Roosevelt se rend compte qu'il
ne sera pas possible,
D'envahir la France en 1943.
Et il souhaite concentrer les efforts
américains dans le Pacifique.
Les deux hommes trouvent un compromis.
Ils décident qu'une fois
l'Afrique du Nord libérée,
Ils mettront au point une
invasion commune de la Sicile.
En Tunisie, les forces de l'Axe,
Avaient mis en place une
forte ligne de défense,
Et avaient obtenu d'importants renforts.
Les Américains qui avancent éprouvent,
De grandes difficultés au col de Kasserine,
Et ce n'est que fin mars qu'une
offensive britannique,
Pourra briser la ligne de l'Axe.
Les actions communes anglo-américaines,
Continuent jusqu'à ce que
les forces de l'Axe,
Se rendent le 11 mai 1943.
275 000 Italiens et Allemands
sont faits prisonniers.
La voie est donc ouverte aux Alliés
pour attaquer la Sicile.
L'opération Husky commence le 10 juillet.
Les débarquements maritimes de la
huitième armée de Montgomery,
Et la septième armée américaine de Patton,
Ont réussi à créer une surprise
tactique presque totale.
L'offensive de la huitième armée sur Messine,
Rencontre cependant une forte
résistance allemande,
Pendant que les Américains se sont
avancés vers l'ouest de la Sicile,
Prenant Palerme le 22 juillet.
A la mi-août, les forces de l'Axe,
Procèdent à une évacuation de la Sicile
sur une grande échelle.
En 38 jours, l'axe perd 160 000 hommes,
Tués, blessés ou faits prisonniers,
Contre 16 000 pertes chez les Alliés,
dix fois moins.
La conquête de la Sicile,
A des conséquences aussi bien
politiques que militaires.
Le 24 juillet,
Mussolini est renversé par
des conspirateurs de l'armée.
Et le nouveau dirigeant, le maréchal Badoglio,
Commence à négocier la paix.
Le jour même, la ville allemande de Hambourg
est anéantie par les bombardiers britanniques.
Malgré les sacrifices des équipages alliés,
Le plus grand coup subi,
Par la machine militaire d'Hitler en 1943,
N'est pas infligé par les
bombardements des Alliés.
Il est porté par l'Armée rouge
sur le front à l'est.
En juillet une offensive de
grande envergure,
Lancée par les blindés allemands à Koursk,
Devient le plus grand combat
de chars de l'histoire.
Tout d'abord pulvérisés par la
défense arrière soviétique,
Les blindés allemands sont finalement,
Écrasés dans des combats mettant
en jeu 1000 chars à la fois.
20 divisions panzer allemandes sont
complètement mises en échec,
Perdant 1500 chars.
Le 3 août, la contre-offensive
soviétique commence.
C'est le début d'une grande avancée,
Qui entraînera en 20 mois,
L'Armée rouge au cœur même de l'Allemagne.
Aujourd'hui, le 3 décembre,
Nous entrons dans la cinquième
année de la guerre,
Et aujourd'hui, la huitième armée,
Après avoir combattu pour
passer d'Égypte en Tunisie,
Puis traversé les mers jusqu'à la Sicile,
A débarqué sur le continent européen.
Nous avions un excellent plan d'attaque,
Et un support aérien plus puissant que jamais.
Il ne peut y avoir qu'une issue
à cette bataille à venir,
Et ce sera un autre succès.
En attendant la victoire,
allons neutraliser les Italiens.
*
Dès les premiers jours de
leur débarquement en Italie,
Les forces d'invasion, tant
britanniques qu'américaines,
Sortent de leur tête de pont et
s'enfoncent à l'intérieur des terres.
Mais les Allemands ne tardent pas à se regrouper.
Seul les canonnades des navires alliés,
Empêchent les contre-attaques,
De faire une percée jusqu'aux
têtes de pont vulnérable.
Six jours après l'invasion par les Alliés,
Le gouvernement italien demande une armistice.
Immédiatement, l'armée allemande occupe Rome.
À Naples, le peuple se rebelle
contre les Allemands.
Des combats sanglants continuent
pendant trois jours.
Voici les informations.
Il y a 2h, l'Italie a déclaré
la guerre à l'Allemagne.
Le maréchal Badoglio,
A qualifié les actes des Allemands,
De sauvagerie envers la population civile,
Et il a déclaré que la paix
ne sera pas possible,
Tant qu'il restera un seul Allemand
sur le sol italien.
Londres, Washington et Moscou,
Ont pris note de la mesure prise par l'Italie.
Son statut sera celui d'un co-belligérant,
Et pas celui d'un allié.
Les conditions de l'armistice
avec le commandement allié,
Restent en vigueur.
Alors que les Alliés commencent par consolider,
Leurs positions dans le sud de l'Italie,
Puis se lancent dans une avancée
lente et coûteuse en direction de Rome,
La stratégie des Alliés dans son ensemble,
Subit un changement extrêmement important.
La conférence de Téhéran de novembre 1943,
Entraîne une décision historique.
Le principal effort des alliés occidentaux
n'aura pas lieu en Italie.
La puissance des Alliés sera
concentrée au contraire,
En Grande-Bretagne pour une
invasion de la France.
Au printemps 1944, 3 millions de combattants,
Sont rassemblés en Angleterre
pour l'invasion à venir.
Des milliers de navires ont d'égorger,
Plus de 5 millions de tonnes
d'équipements militaires américains.
Un commandement commun anglo-américain,
Est créé avec le général Eisenhower,
En tant que commandant suprême des Alliés.
Montgomery est rappelé d'Italie,
Pour commander toutes les
forces terrestres,
Pendant la phase d'ouverture
de la campagne.
Après de nombreux pourparlers,
La décision est finalement prise
d'attaquer en Normandie,
À l'ouest de la Seine,
Plutôt que dans la région du Pas de Calais,
beaucoup plus fortifiée.
Pour induire les Allemands en erreur,
Une campagne massive de
désinformation est lancée.
Les Alliés échangent d'innombrables
messages radio,
Avec une troupe d'invasion non
existante située dans le Kent.
Un plus grand nombre de raids de bombardement
sont dirigés sur le Pas de Calais,
Plutôt que sur la Normandie,
la véritable cible.
Adolf Hitler sait que l'invasion de
la France est une certitude.
La question est de savoir
où elle va avoir lieu.
Von Rundstedt, le commandant en
chef d'Hitler à l'Ouest,
Pense que l'attaque alliée se
fera sur le Pas de Calais.
Rommel, qui est en contact direct avec Hitler,
Et qui bénéficie pratiquement d'une
indépendance dans le commandement,
Est convaincu que la cible, c'est la Normandie.
Hitler est d'accord avec lui,
Mais contrairement à son habitude,
Il ne soutient pas le jugement
de Rommel de façon décisive.
Il divise de façon égale les forces
terrestres à l'est et à l'ouest de la Seine.
Rommel et Von Rundstedt sont également
en désaccord sur la meilleure façon,
De faire face au débarquement.
Rommel préfère détruire les
envahisseurs sur les plages.
Von Rundstedt pense que les blindés allemands,
Devraient être tenus en réserve,
Pour lancer une contre-offensive,
Après le débarquement des Alliés.
Une fois encore, Hitler ne prend pas parti au débat.
Aucune des 2 défenses n'est
véritablement préparée.
Alors que les Allemands débattent,
La phase d'ouverture de
l'opération Overlord,
L'invasion de la France par les
Alliés est déjà en cours.
Un assaut aérien de grande envergure,
Sur les routes, les ponts,
les gares de tri et les canaux,
Coupe les moyens de communication,
Et isole les blindés allemands
dans le Pas de Calais.
C'est une façon idéale,
D'utiliser la puissance tactique aérienne.
Alors que le rassemblement des
troupes alliées,
Est mené à bien en Grande-Bretagne,
La guerre en Italie immobilise
23 divisions allemandes.
Les débarquements alliés à Anzio,
Entraînent de nombreuses
contre-attaque allemandes,
Et la huitième armée lance un assaut
direct sur la ligne Gustave,
Farouchement défendu par les
puissantes formations allemandes.
Le monastère au sommet de la
colline de Monte Cassino,
Bloque l'avancée des Alliés sur Rome.
Le 15 février, le monastère a été bombardé
par les avions alliés.
Malgré tout, les Allemands
tiennent leur position,
Au milieu des décombres.
Le 11 mai, les unités britanniques,
Françaises, polonaises,
américaines et canadiennes,
Organisent une attaque déterminante sur l'abbaye.
La prise de Monte Cassino le 17 mai
ouvre enfin la route de Rome.
Le commandant de la cinquième armée américaine,
Le général Clark,
A maintenant une chance inespérée
d'encercler les deux armées allemandes.
Pourtant, le 4 juin,
Il pénètre dans la capitale de l'Italie,
Permettant aux Allemands de
se replier vers le nord,
Et d'établir une nouvelle ligne défensive.
La victoire en Italie va donc échapper
aux Alliés jusqu'en mai 1945.
La date de l'invasion de la Normandie
a été fixée au 5 juin.
Ce jour-là, la lune et la marée seront favorables.
Mais tout dépend du temps et les prévisions
météorologiques ne sont pas bonnes.
Les hommes et les équipements déjà embarqués,
Le cauchemar des stratèges alliés
semblent prendre forme.
Un violent orage arrive de l'Atlantique
et s'abat sur les ports de la Manche.
Si l'invasion a lieu,
Les terrains de débarquement seront
le théâtre d'un chaos inimaginable.
Le 5 juin, les météorologues prévoient
une éclaircie pour le lendemain matin.
Eisenhower, fait face à un choix difficile.
Une erreur pourrait entraîner
la mort de 150 000 hommes.
Cependant, la force d'intervention
dans cette attente fébrile,
Ne peut être indéfiniment maintenue dans l'expectative.
Eisenhower décide de partir.
À la veille de cette grande aventure,
J'envoie mes meilleurs souhaits à
tous les soldats de l'Empire alliés.
Il nous est donné l'honneur de porter,
Le dernier coup pour la liberté
qui restera dans l'histoire.
Et dans les jours meilleurs qui nous attendent,
Les hommes parleront avec fierté
de ce que nous avons fait.
Nous avons une cause grande et juste.
Prions pour que le Seigneur Dieu
soit avec nous dans la bataille,
Et que cette providence particulière
nous aide dans le combat.
Je veux que tous les soldats,
Sachent que je suis convaincu,
Que les opérations que nous
sommes sur le point de commencer,
Nous conduiront vers la victoire.
Le cœur plein de bravoure et dans
l'enthousiasme pour le combat,
Avançons vers la victoire.
À l'aube du 6 juin,
l'opération Overlord commence.
Les premières troupes aéroportées ont
déjà atterri derrière les lignes allemandes.
Le premier contingent de la
21ᵉ armée de Montgomery,
Fort de 150 000 hommes,
s'embarque pour la France.
Ici, la BBC, ceci est un bulletin spécial.
Le jour J est arrivé.
Tôt ce matin, les Alliés ont commencé l'assaut,
Sur le côté nord ouest de la
forteresse européenne d'Hitler.
Les premières informations officielles
sont arrivées juste après 9h30,
Quand les quartiers généraux suprêmes
de la Force expéditionnaire alliés,
Ont émis le communiqué numéro un.
Celui-ci indique que,
Sous le commandement du général Eisenhower,
Les forces maritimes alliées,
Soutenues par une puissante force aérienne,
ont commencé.
C'est le jour et c'est l'heure,
Le ciel s'illumine au dessus
des côtes européennes,
Alors qu'ils arrivent.
Le ciel est plus clair et
la mer plus brillante.
Mais le long de la côte,
Il y a un écran de fumée dense,
Provoqué par les cuirassés et les navires
de guerre qui tirent sans arrêt.
Le soleil lance maintenant des rayons de lumière,
C'est comme si c'était un présage.
La façon dont il vient de sortir,
Juste au moment où nous arrivons.
Le ciel est clair et la mer est
une masse d'argent scintillante,
Avec tous ces bateaux la traversant,
Et les grands navires de guerre au fond,
Tirant d'incessants coups de
feu en direction du rivage.
Voilà maintenant les canots de
débarquement qui nous dépassent.
Les plus lents sont laissés à l'arrière,
Chacun d'entre eux joue son rôle
et arrive au bon moment,
Pour remplir la tâche qui lui est impartie,
Des destroyers, des corvettes, des patrouilleurs.
J'entends le bruit des coups de feu antiaériens.
Je n'arrive pas encore à voir si ce
sont les nôtres qui sont attaqués.
Il y a un énorme nuage de fumée
le long du rivage,
Dû non-seulement à l'écran de fumée,
Mais à ces terribles bombardements.
Tous les navires tirent maintenant.
J'ai du mal à imaginer quelque chose
semblable à cette parade de bateaux,
Tels des soldats défilant en rang.
Je n'ai jamais rien vu qui exprime
autant ce sentiment intense,
D'un même but partagé par autant de navires,
Et par des centaines de milliers de combattants,
Qui sont à présent en train de
débarquer sur cette côte européenne,
Pour remplir la plus grande tâche
qu'ils n'aient jamais eu à accomplir.
Je dois arrêter mon enregistrement maintenant,
Parce que le temps est venu pour
moi de mettre mon sac sur le dos,
Et de me préparer à débarquer sur le rivage,
Et c'est un grand jour.
Lorsque la première vague de l'infanterie
alliée arrive sur les plages,
Personne ne sait ce qui les attend.
Mais le grand secret, le lieu et
l'heure de l'invasion a été gardé.
Hitler n'entend parler du
débarquement en Normandie,
Qu'en fin de matinée,
Et il est déjà tard dans la soirée,
Avant que Rommel ne puisse
rejoindre ses quartiers généraux.
Entre temps, les Alliés ont
débarqué 150 000 troupes,
Ne perdant que 2000 hommes.
Il devient alors impossible de les repousser.
Hitler continue à penser que
la principale poussée des Alliés,
Se portera sur le Pas de Calais,
Et que les débarquements en Normandie
ne sont que pure tactique.
Il interdit à ses forces de se replier
vers de nouvelles positions défensives,
Et ne se rend pas compte que
le principal objectif des alliés,
Est le port de Cherbourg.
À la consternation de ces généraux,
Hitler met toute sa confiance
dans une nouvelle arme secrète,
La bombe volante V1.
Le premier raid de V1 sur la Grande-Bretagne
commence le 12 juin.
L'effet est encore plus terrifiant
qu'une flotte de bombardiers allemands.
Un seul V1 transporte presque
une tonne de puissant explosif,
Et il n'est pas possible de lancer
des alertes pour les raids qui arrivent.
La menace est constante.
La moitié des 1500 V1 lancés en
juin explose dans la campagne.
Mais ceux qui réussissent à passer
tuent plus de 500 Londoniens chaque semaine.
La confiance d'Hitler dans
le V1 n'est pas justifiée.
La plupart des Anglais pensent que
la guerre sera terminée en quelques mois,
Et que la nouvelle arme d'Hitler,
Ne peut pas avoir de véritable
impact sur leur moral.
La guerre sera gagnée ou perdue,
Non pas dans le ciel au dessus de l'Angleterre,
Mais sur les champs de bataille en France.
Le 27 juin, Cherbourg tombe aux mains des Alliés.
Mais à l'Est, une puissante force allemande,
De 7 divisions blindées et de 2 divisions d'infanterie
barre l'avancée des Anglais à Caen.
Le 8 juillet, les unités de la seconde armée
réussissent à pénétrer dans la ville,
Mais sont bloquées sur les ponts de l'Orne.
L'opération Goodwood de Montgomery,
Une avancée par 3 divisions blindées britanniques
vers l'arrière des défenses allemandes,
Est bloquée elle aussi.
Pendant que les opérations
des Britanniques à Caen,
Attirent la majeure partie des blindés allemands,
La première armée américaine se bat pour
se frayer un chemin vers Saint-Lô,
Le 18 juillet.
Après qu'une féroce offensive aérienne
alliée ait brisé les lignes allemandes à Avranches,
La troisième armée de Patton,
S'engouffre dans la brèche
pour arriver en Bretagne.
Faisant route vers le nord,
Patton avance derrière les blindés allemands
et fonce vers la capitale de la France.
Le 19 août, les forces américaines
s'approchant de Paris,
Le Conseil national français de la Résistance,
Donne l'ordre à ses partisans de s'insurger.
Pendant 4 jours, les combats de rue font rage,
dans l'ensemble de la ville.
Les dirigeants français sont résolus
à ce que la capitale,
Soit libérée par ses propres citoyens.
Le 23 août, après un combat implacable,
Les forces de la résistance parviennent
à libérer la plus grande partie de Paris.
Au sud de la ville,
Les troupes françaises combattant
aux côtés du cinquième corps américain,
Se rapprochent de la capitale.
La quatrième division blindée française,
A déjà pénétré dans la banlieue.
Deux jours plus tard,
Charles de Gaulle entre dans la capitale.
Voici les informations.
Paris a été libérée.
Un communiqué que nous venons de
recevoir du général Koenig,
Annonce que la capitale de la France,
A été libérée par les Forces
françaises de l'intérieur.
Onze jours après la libération de Paris,
Hitler cherche à prendre sa revanche,
À l'aide d'une nouvelle arme secrète.
Deux fusées V2 sont tirées sur la ville,
Mais toutes deux explosent en vol
sans causer de dégâts.
Deux jours plus tard, le V2 prend
la Grande-Bretagne pour cible.
Plus de 1000 fusées sont tirées sur Londres,
Et plus de 500 d'entre elles
atteignent leur cible,
Tuant 2700 personnes.
Il n'existe aucune défense efficace.
Ce n'est que lorsque les forces alliées,
Auront pris leur base de lancement,
Que la menace des V2 prendra fin.
Tandis qu'à l'ouest, les Alliés
se battent en direction du Rhin,
À l'est, l'Armée rouge avance sur tous les fronts.
Le 12 janvier 1945, les forces russes
font une percée vers le sud de Varsovie,
Et avancent vers la Silésie.
Varsovie tombe le 17 janvier et au nord,
2 armées russes envahissent une
vaste étendue de la Prusse-Orientale,
Isolant ainsi un grand nombre de troupes allemandes.
Puis l'offensive soviétique,
forte de 180 divisions,
Avance de 350 kilomètres en 15 jours.
Le front de l'Armée rouge se trouve maintenant
à 150 kilomètres de Berlin à peine.
Bonjour ici la BBC,
Les Américains ont passé le Rhin.
Les quartiers généraux suprêmes ont annoncé,
Il y a quelques minutes,
Que la première armée des Etats-Unis du général Hodgers avait atteint le Rhin.
Les troupes l'ont traversé pour
établir une tête de pont,
Quelque part au sud de Cologne.
Bonjour, ici la BBC, Stewart McPherson,
En direct de l'Allemagne.
Il suffit de passer quelques minutes
parmi nos troupes qui avancent vers le Rhin,
Pour ressentir l'état d'esprit presque frénétique
qui règne au sein de chaque formation.
Ce matin, j'ai traversé un des ponts du Rhin,
Et tout le long de la route,
Je fus pris dans la bousculade et
l'élan de chaque formation.
Avant l'avancée sur le Rhin,
Il était toujours important de
ralentir à l'approche d'un pont,
Mais ce n'est plus le cas à présent.
Les choses ont changé,
Alors que j'avais à peine avancé
le nez de ma voiture vers le pont,
Un policier anglais m'a crié :
"Vas-y vieux, traverse le pont à toute vitesse !"
*
La traversée du Rhin par les Alliés marque
la phase finale de la guerre en Europe.
Le front occidental de l'Allemagne,
Est toujours tenu par 70 divisions allemandes,
Qui se battent obstinément pour chaque
centimètre carré de leur patrie.
Mais à l'est,
L'Armée rouge a rassemblé
2 millions et demi d'hommes,
Pour l'assaut final sur la capitale de l'Allemagne.
Trois groupes d'armées soviétiques,
Accompagnés de 6000 chars,
42 000 fusils et 7500 avions,
Sont prêts à s'enfoncer au sud
et au nord de Berlin.
La dernière offensive de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale,
Commence le 16 avril.
En trois jours, les Soviétiques
franchissent les faubourgs de Berlin.
Au 25 avril, la ville est totalement encerclée.
Le jour même, les armées soviétiques et
américaines se rejoignent à l'Elbe.
Le sort du Troisième Reich est scellé.
L'ouest et l'est se sont rejoints.
À 5h20, mercredi après-midi,
Le 25 avril 1945,
Les troupes américaines du 12ᵉ corps
d'armée du général Bradley,
Sont entrées en contact avec les Soviétiques,
Du premier corps d'armée
ukrainien du maréchal Khoja,
À proximité de la ville allemande de Tourgan sur l'Elbe.
Ceci est la nouvelle que toutes
les populations alliées attendaient.
L'allemagne nazie, chancelant
vers son effondrement total,
A été coupée en deux.
*
Maintenant, nous vivons les moments
les plus graves des temps modernes.
Je vous prie de vous rendre
compte que le combat continue.
Je dirai seulement,
Que les hommes qui sont morts
pendant la bataille de Berlin,
Ont donné leur vie pour montrer
que quoi qu'il arrive,
L'Allemagne vivra.
*
Aucune torture, aucune oppression,
Aucune mesure de tyrannie de
la part de l'ennemi,
Ne parviendra à anéantir l'Allemagne.
L'Allemagne vivra car les Allemands ont
en eux le secret de la vie,
L'endurance, la volonté et la patience.
Et c'est pourquoi, je vous dis ces derniers mots,
Vous ne m'entendrez sans doute pas
parler pendant quelques mois.
Et je le déclare Ich liebe deutschland heil Hitler et adieu.
***
Alors qu'Adolf Hitler,
Dans son blockhaus enfoncé profondément
au dessous de la chancellerie du Reich,
Refuse de concevoir la possibilité d'une défaite,
L'Armée rouge se fraie un chemin
jusqu'au cœur de la ville.
En 18 jours, 93 divisions
allemandes ont été détruites.
À présent, 30 000 défenseurs désespérés,
Et 2 millions de civils se
retrouvent au milieu d'un enfer.
Le 30 avril, les unités soviétiques
atteignent le Reichstag.
Ici Londres,
Ceci est un flash d'information.
La radio allemande vient juste
d'annoncer qu'Hitler est mort.
Je répète, la radio allemande vient
*
L'ordre d'Hitler de continuer le combat,
A coûté la vie à plus d'un million d'hommes.
L'armée rouge en a perdu 305 000.
125 000 civils allemands ont péri
dans les décombres de la ville.
6000 se sont suicidés.
Berlin a été pratiquement anéantie.
*
Ici, le service intérieur de la BBC,
Nous interrompons les émissions
pour faire l'annonce suivante :.
Nous avons toutes les raisons de croire que,
Conformément aux dispositions prises
par les trois grandes puissances,
Une déclaration officielle sera
diffusée par le Premier ministre,
À 3h de l'après-midi, demain 8 mai.
*
Hier, a 2h41 du matin,
Aux quartiers généraux du général Eisenhower,
Le général Leeuwarden, représentant
du haut commandement allemand,
Et le grand amiral Donitz,
chef désigné de l'État allemand,
Ont signé l'accord inconditionnel de
reddition de toutes les forces allemandes,
Terrestres, maritimes et aériennes en Europe,
Et l'ont remise à la force expéditionnaire alliée,
En même temps qu'au haut commandement soviétique.
Nous pouvons nous permettre une
brève période de réjouissances.
*
La Seconde Guerre mondiale
n'est pas encore terminée.
Le combat contre le Japon
durera encore 3 mois.
Cependant, le plus grand ennemi a été
vaincu de façon décisive et inconditionnelle.
Et pour l'Europe, le long cauchemar touche à sa fin.
Les Anglais ont une satisfaction unique,
Celle de savoir qu'en faisant face à
Hitler dans les journées sombres de 1940,
Et en préservant un îlot de liberté
à la lisière de l'empire d'Hitler,
Ce sont eux qui ont rendu possible la victoire.